- [Gary] These
are losing players
that if you put this much
in their cup, they're full.
Other people, right?
Like you and me. Right here.
But I have to know when
you're just about to go.
And then I take it out.
We just emptied your cup.
You can now go
eat a lot more shit.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Same Shame" by Ron Gilmore)
You should really actually
be able to figure this out.
- [Man] Yeah.
- You need to figure
out who's doing work.
Bro, who are the other
Alexa fuckin' voice partners?
That reminds me.
We're looking to hire
somebody for Patrick's team.
So if you've built Alexa skills,
what's Google's officlal called?
- Actions.
- [Gary] Or Google Actions,
or if you're into that world
and know a shit load about it,
please hit Patrick up.
I understand arbitrage.
I understand brand
and event and marketing.
Anything that is
leverageable far beyond.
When you host the
party in high school,
you host the
party in high school.
It's leverage.
And where'd you grow up?
- New York.
- [Gary] Got it.
Nice.
(Man 2 laughs)
I'd like to be 24, good looking
and living on the beach.
- I'd take 24.
- [Gary] Me, too.
I'd take 24 and ugly
and living in a
fucking, just time.
I would pay for time.
In anything you do,
when you hit that moment.
And I'm in that
moment on everything
that I've been
doing for a decade.
I just really
understand what to do
on Facebook and Instagram
in a way that I'm at the
top of my craft right now.
- Yeah, I can feel it.
- [Gary] I appreciate it.
This is not a joke.
This is February 2006,
YouTube is five months old.
I'm like if I do Jets content,
I will end up
being on SportsCenter.
- Yeah.
It's amazing
when you're good at,
like I just basically knew.
Now the phone wasn't here yet
so what happened
was that happened
and that made me jump on Twitter
the second I saw it, too.
Because I knew
that was connected.
So in the early days,
I just knew that I was gonna,
and by the way,
you know what's weird?
I'm still kind of
weirdly doing it now.
If you gobble up
all the attention,
well then you can become the
President of the United States.
("Cash Rules" by Ron Gilmore)
I want you to tell
me what you wanna do,
and then I wanna see if
I can make it 100% happen.
You know all the
pieces right now,
you're watching everything.
Like, what do you want to do?
That's some people's cups.
These are losing players.
That if you put this much
in their cup, they're full.
Other people, right?
Like you and me, right here.
But I have to know
when you're just about to go
and then I take it out.
We just emptied your cup.
You can now go
eat a lot more shit.
- [Tyler] You went heavy
coffee, or did you
pour water into it?
- I was making a demonstration.
- [Tyler] I like that.
- [Other Tyler] I'm really
into these demonstrations.
- It's rear.
What's up, man?
- Barack.
- Barack. Real pleasure.
- Austin. Nice to meet you.
- Austin, nice to meet you, man.
- Wow, so many
videos have been done here.
- There have been a lot here.
- Yeah, it's insane
coming to the actual,
to visit the
station of this all.
- Thanks, man.
- Thanks for the experience
of letting us come in.
- Yeah, how's it been?
- It's great.
- Definitely learning a lot.
- If you are collecting debt,
and you're going to
college for marketing
or entrepreneurship,
if you're that,
you're actually pulling off
one of the worst things
in the world to do right now.
That breaks my heart.
Now if you're
going to be a lawyer,
if you're not collecting debt,
and mom and dad
are taking care of it,
that's fine.
I'm not mad at college.
Like, if you wanna
work like a Bain,
you need to go to
an Ivy League school
and get that degree.
But if you're going to college
to work in marketing
and communications,
or to be an entrepreneur,
and you're collecting debt,
because your parents made you
or you think
that's the right thing,
you're basically pulling off
the worst move in the world.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm good.
- [Gary] Such a pleasure.
- It's such a
pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] How are things?
- Wonderful.
- Hey, India.
- [Gary] How's your
trip into New York?
- Rainy and late but good.
- Yes. When'd you get in?
- Wednesday night.
I came in from
Rapid City, South Dakota.
- Is that where you live?
- I live in Omaha, Nebraska.
- That's what I thought, yeah.
- I've done some work
in the Rapid City area.
- Got it. Very cool.
How you doin', India?
- Really good.
Time is long out here.
- She told me she
loves Shout House, though.
- She loves it.
She loves it, she loves it.
(laughter)
How's it going?
How's everything
going with VaynerTalent?
- Love it. Love the team.
And we're getting
some good success.
I think you heard we got--
- That's why I
emailed you, yeah.
- Yeah. Within in just
like four videos and--
- That's a real thing.
- It's huge.
- People don't understand
there's a massive difference
between sales and branding.
- Yeah.
And there's so many
people in my industry
they're like now
what are you doing?
And give it all for free.
And they go why
would you do that?
Then they won't pay you.
And I've had to
explain over and over again
it's like you feed them,
you feed the tribe,
and you give it away for free--
- Doing the right
thing always plays out.
- You know, and that's
been my philosophy for years.
And so when I first
heard about the concept,
it was like I'm all in.
- I love it.
When I tell you
I have zero expectations,
- [Cy] I believe it.
- Ever.
- [Cy] Yeah.
- That's why
I'm so fuckin' happy.
And I mean from like my wife,
from like my mom,
like everything.
- [Cy] If you can
unhook from expectations
and thoughts about the future--
- I just never.
That's exact, I mean.
- [Cy] If you don't
have expectations,
you never have disappointment.
It saves just a long life.
- 100%. I'm always
pleasantly surprised.
- [Cy] I love it. Well yeah,
everything's great then.
- Yeah, you know what it is?
Everything is what it is.
- [Cy] It is what it is.
- You know what I mean?
Like when I'm disappointed,
oh, I'm disappointed,
because that person stinks.
But I don't expect
because I'm empathetic.
I actually think
it comes from empathy.
- [Cy] It does.
- It's like, I'm
just like listen,
she has her own shit.
I also think, I wonder
what the mix between,
I'd love to get
your perspective.
So I think what
really is driving me
is the mix that I'm
extremely empathetic
and extremely talented.
And I mean that.
I know it's funny to say.
But, I just don't
need anybody's help.
Like, I think,
when somebody knows
oh shit, I need
my business partner
to make the money,
well then it's scary.
- [Cy] Yeah.
- I don't think
anybody's better
at anything that I do.
It's just a very good feeling.
- [Cy] It is that confidence
in I can get what I need
and do what I need to do
but they care about people.
- 100%.
- [Cy] I think that's the key.
- You know what else is
interesting as we're talking,
I also just realized,
as we're building,
I fully believe in
myself to get what I can get,
I also don't need anything.
- [Cy] So you've
got nothing to lose.
- Right. Like I'm
gonna get everything,
but the level in which, like,
I just don't, it's why
I wanna buy the Jets.
I don't wanna buy the Jets,
I wanna try to buy the Jets.
- [Cy] Yeah.
- That's the KPI.
- [Cy] Yeah. Well, attachment
is the source of all suffering.
As soon as you
attach to an expectation,
or you attach to a need
or, it's like, the
ultimate freedom for me
is when you have
nothing else to lose.
And then everything's a gain.
("Don't Stress" by Julian Avila)
- Just a hardcore day.
Meeting, meetings,
meetings, meetings,
meetings, meetings.
Meetings.
The lawyer.
("Don't Stress" by Julian Avila)
How's today going?
- [Steve] Awesome.
- [Gary] Yeah?
Thanks for being
here. Is everybody here?
Hey, my man.
I use LinkedIn,
Instagram stories,
and Facebook like a media site.
The team can take content,
I approve the content,
then it goes out.
As far as everything else,
it's all done by my hand.
Now the team makes
the Instagram creative
that I put out on
my main Instagram page.
But I approve the
pictures and the words
and then they make
them and then I post them.
Every single comment
that you've ever seen
as Gary Vaynerchuk
has been by my hands.
All of them.
Every single tweet,
every single everything.
So, every reply in the comments,
every time you see me in YouTube
or in my Facebook
page, like replying,
that's me.
I read the
comments on every place
because that's
my consumer insights
which is why I think
I'm ahead of everybody.
People undervalue
community management
'cause they
think it's being nice.
And giving back
to the community.
It's not being nice,
it's the insights
to your next strategy.
We don't understand
the brain, like humans,
and I think
it's really powerful.
It's the operating
system of the ultimate species
in the universe.
Right? When you
start breaking it down,
it's kind of interesting, right?
Like, holy shit,
our brain is the
operating system
to the most powerful
species in the universe.
So my intuition is that
the reason it's so right
is 'cause it's
capable of doing it,
but we don't allow it to.
So, I will give
you a good analogy.
I've been working out
and getting my shit together,
we've been a real,
like almost rehab,
for the last month or two.
You might have
noticed, I've been like really,
I'm holding my neck.
Your brain doesn't
allow you to roll over
your worst spot.
It actually protects you.
Like, I'm doing my traps now,
I did my adductor,
I'm doing my neck.
I can't get there.
I know I'm trying to get there.
Like, right now,
as I was sitting,
you might have saw, right?
Some of you noticed?
I'm trying to get the spot.
It won't let me.
That's so cool, right?
Like, I know where it is.
I literally can't.
It's really cool, right?
So you need
your trainer to do it
and so I think that's happening.
That's the
physical manifestation
of what the brain's power is.
The mental manistation is
it knows what to do,
we're doing things to stop it.
I think I've tapped into that
and now
I communicate towards it.
And I don't think
I'm even at my crescendo,
I'm chippin',
I'm chippin', I'm chippin'.
Maybe in seven years I'm
may be communicating it better
but a lot of what
my shit is is that.
What I'm really good at
is just getting to
the fuckin' punchline.
Right? The reason I am always
interrupting people is fuck,
let's just get to the punchline.
("Vacation" By Julian Avila)
- I get it.
- And I just,
but I, I know you do,
but I'm empathetic that we
haven't danced for a long time.
And hard to fully
get how little people,
how much people have to say,
and how little they have to say.
Like, I'm 18 minutes
late from 20 minutes away
for a family
dinner with my sister
and brother who I never see.
- Oh, okay.
- I'm not doing
that to, I'm doing that
for you to really
know how in it I really am.
- And I--
- I feel like people
think I won't meet with them
because I want to
do a selfie with a fan,
- I don't think that.
- But you understand, right?
- I do.
- [Gary] Thank you.
Ty, get me outta here.
I'm gonna go
meet with the family.
Siblings dinner.
My sister and my brother.
My sister Liz, a lot of you
don't even know about her.
That's our inside family joke.
Have a good weekend.
("Vacation" By Julian Avila)